welcome to Kashmir want to escape from
the stress of the city here you'll find
beautiful valleys breathtaking nature
ancient culture Wars terrorist attacks
and systematic violence
yes Kashmir is the last place on earth
you'd want to go and in the last few
months this region situated between
India and Pakistan has been making news
headlines again could it lead to nuclear
war well in this video we're going to
explore that possibility
[Applause]
[Music]
there are only three sporting events
that gather an audience of more than a
billion people worldwide the opening of
an Olympic Games a FIFA World Cup final
and an india-pakistan cricket tornavoz
[Applause]
heard that right cricket is the national
sport in both India and Pakistan two of
the most populated countries on the
planet and the rivalry between them it
goes way beyond sports Kashmir suffers
from the worst attack in 30 years and
believe me this is no small matter both
India and Pakistan have nuclear weapons
the main reason for their fighting is a
region called Kashmir both countries are
in dispute over control of this area so
in February 2000 and 19 a terrorist
group called JC Mohammed organized one
of the worst terrorist attacks in
Kashmir pan India answered this with the
first bombing in sunny Pakistani
territory in decades the situation it
really could have been more tense
so the questions are we about to witness
a nuclear war why do India and Pakistan
hate each other so much well today we're
going to answer those questions and
we're going to do it with the help of
our friend Xander Schneider a political
analyst in one of the voices from the
reconsider media podcast you'll often
hear about on these videos hey Simon and
flow to all of you visual politics
subscribers out there as you mentioned
India and Pakistan are in a standoff of
sorts and really have been since they
became independent countries
[Music]
today we're gonna talk a lot about
nuclear weapons but more importantly
we're going to talk about nuclear
doctrine can all of this lead to nuclear
war I don't think so in this video we're
gonna discuss why well we get too bored
of that but before we do let's take a
look back at the history of the Titans
after World War two all of the Indian
territories became independent from the
British Empire but there was a bit of a
problem there were two big religious
groups here Muslims on the one hands and
Hindus on the other so what did the UK
do well easy they sent all of the
Muslims to one blazes and they called
that Pakistan and they send all of the
Hindus to another and they called that
India but there was still one problem
there were many areas where it wasn't
clear if there was a Muslim or a Hindu
majority in Kashmir or well it was one
of those regions basically most of the
Kashmir citizens were Muslim but their
governor their Maharaja
happens to be Indian this is why the
British decided that Kashmir would be an
independent nation which made everyone
happy right
no in fact quite the opposite just two
months after Kashmir declared its
independence Pakistan invaded it so the
Maharaja asked India for help
this is how these two brand-new states
India and Pakistan started a war the
results cite from thousands dead and
millions displaced is that 1949 Kashmir
was divided into two parts one for India
and one for Pakistan but if you thought
that a border was going to be enough to
keep everyone happy think again
India and Pakistan would go on to fight
three more wars over control of this
whole territory now wars between India
and Pakistan tend to follow a similar
pattern Pakistan start for the wars and
India wins them and after all at the end
of the day India is a more powerful
country as a larger population a larger
military and more money so we've already
reached the 1960s in our timeline here
back then the Indian Prime Minister was
the woman were picturing here Indira
Gandhi
and there are two things that you should
know about her first she had no familial
connection whatsoever to Mahatma Gandhi
and the second is that she had nothing
to do with peace and non-violence
basically we're talking about a woman
who forced six million poor people to
yeah vasectomies so this woman the noid
as she was by the Pakistani attacks
essentially said this we're getting
some nuclear bombs and therefore in 1967
India started its nuclear program
[Music]
since then the Pakistani army hasn't
dared to directly attack it's now
nuclear neighbor instead Kashmiri
citizens have been suffering
never-ending attacks from all kinds of
Pakistani terrorist groups and if
terrorism wasn't enough the Indian
government does not around either
since 1990 Kashmir has been under
martial law
this means the constant repression of
its citizens and if you thought the
situation couldn't get any more
complicated is that really possible yes
because in 1998 things took an
unexpected turn let's have a look at
that
standoff fighting a nuclear country is
like playing cricket without bats that
is why even leave Pakistan is poorer
than India Zola Kivar Ali Bhutto who was
the president of Pakistan back then had
a very clear goal the grass or leaves
even go hungry but we will get one of
our own news Zulfiqar Ali Bhutto this is
now in the year 1998 Pakistan conducted
its first nuclear tests Pakistan has
been obliged to exercise the nuclear
option due to weaponization of India's
nuclear program this has led to the
collapse of the existential deterrence
and had radically altered the strategic
balance in our region and this is how we
get to the Mexican standoff a Mexican
standoff as a situation when none of the
participants have any way of winning so
they're basically waiting for someone to
make a false move but even though both
India and Pakistan now have nuclear
bombs there is one area where they
differ then nuclear doctrines India has
a no first use doctrine this means they
are ready to make use of their nukes
only if they've been attacked by the
same kind of weapons
[Music]
[Applause]
Pakistan's nuclear doctrine is different
it does allow for first use of nuclear
weapons if they are invaded with a
sufficiently large ground force in this
doctrine tactical weapons play a very
important role you see when it comes to
nuclear weapons there are two high-level
categories of strategic nuclear weapons
and tactical ones strategic nuclear
weapons are those that can take out an
entire city and are usually launched
from thousands of miles away on a
ballistic missile or dropped from a
strategic bomber tactical nuclear
weapons on the other hand are smaller
yield and meant to be used on a
battlefield and close proximity to
maneuvering forces this January Pakistan
tested a short-range ballistic missile
equipped to carry tactical nuclear
warheads although this is definitely not
the first nuclear delivery vehicle that
Pakistan has in its arsenal
dan equips military with tactical loop
capable missile in other words Pakistan
is compensating for its smaller military
might with a more aggressive nuclear
doctrine if India attacks them they
could use the tactical weapons easily
and even destroy the nuclear silos on
Indian territory and if you think this
is a very irresponsible nuclear doctrine
for a country well hold on a second
because you haven't seen anything yes in
Pakistan the nuclear button is not in
the government's hands but rather it's
in the Army's in this country the
military in the government there go
rather different ways and the Pakistani
army is really quite scary
basically there are many reasons to
believe that the Army is supporting
several terrorist organizations and this
explains news like this
was military to cancel three hundred
million dollars in Pakistan aid over
terror groups for example you might
remember a chap called Osama bin Laden
remember where he was when he was
finally found well yes that was in
Pakistan
more specifically next to the cackled
military academy which is sort of the
Pakistani equivalent of West Point and
what types of terrorist organizations
might allegedly be connected to the
Pakistani military well on one hand you
have groups that support the Taliban in
Afghanistan for example on the other we
have groups like Josh and Muhammad which
fight to gain control of Kashmir so no
matter how hard the Pakistani government
tries to cut ties with New Delhi both
the Pakistani army and the terrorists
they make those plans backfire and well
how does India respond to all of this
that's basically by improving their
nuclear arsenal and what do you do when
your rival neighbor knows where you have
all your nuclear silos well we're gonna
tell you right now can you imagine
someone like John Elway the legendary
sportsman becoming the American
presidents well this is exactly what
happened to Pakistan their new president
is Imran Khan the man who led his
country to victory in the Cricket World
Cup
just like his predecessors Imran Khan
has tried to improve relations between
India and Pakistan and this is when Josh
and Mohammad organized one of the worst
massacres in Kashmir in recent memory
and this is when Narendra Modi
essentially said something like this
hey Pakistan Pakistan come over there
come over here we're having a lottery
and the prize is a punch in the face and
you've got all the tickets
[Music]
in other words for the first time in
decades the Indian Army bombed Pakistani
territory this means they didn't attack
the Pakistani part of Kashmir but
Pakistan itself but hold on a second
because this is not the end of our story
remember that Mexican standoff situation
well India has made a hell of a move and
this move has a name the I earnest
arahant
these so-called enemies destructor your
submarine I&S our ahan completes patrol
country's nuclear triad operational
remember I told you that Pakistan could
use their strategic weapons to destroy
Indian nuclear silos well the Indians
were aware of this and that's why they
got nuclear submarine the advantage of a
nuclear submarine is that you can have
your nuclear arsenal constantly moving
around underwater it's harder to find
and therefore it's harder to destroy and
this is why the Pakistani army is so
nervous and this is the point where the
media started talking about a would-be
nuclear war but is this really likely
well we have a visual politic we don't
really think so why well first of all
even though India attacked Pakistan they
just bombed some terrorist training
camps this means they didn't actually
cross any red lines that Pakistan would
consider an invasion so what was this
llama buds response to all of this well
some air strikes but let's be honest
they're the last country to want a
nuclear war just have a look called the
former Pakistani president said
[Music]
attack with one nuke India may finish us
with twenty atavism of Schroth
this explains why Pakistan didn't wait
any longer than three days to release
the Indian pilot that they captured and
in case they were tempted at some point
to strike back India has made things
very very clear
[Music]
Navy deploys aircraft carrier and
nuclear subs to deter misadventures by
Pakistan so again so far it seems like
neither country is really thinking about
an actual nuclear war so then well who
is this all really helping well so far
the clearest winner is Narendra Modi the
Indian Prime Minister yes dear viewers
India is celebrating a presidential
election and all this conflict with
Pakistan has helped Modi rise up in the
polls all the clears victory in Indian
elections as a position Congress party
concedes but don't worry because in the
following weeks we'll talk about the
Indian elections in depth they're the
world's biggest elections and of course
if you're going to dedicate a video to
them right here on visual politic if you
don't want to miss that one please don't
forget to subscribe to this channel and
hit that Bell button so you'll receive a
notification whenever we post a brand
new video meanwhile the question for you
is do you think India and Pakistan can
ever be friends can this conflict get
any worse after the Indian elections
well please leave your answer in the
comments section below and don't forget
to visit our friends from the ricans
intermedia podcast he's sure to check
out our podcast reconsider where we
don't do the thinking for you
just visit reconsider mediacom slash
podcast see you there also if you like
this video give us a thumbs up and as
always I'll see you next time
[Music]